Speaker 1: Vaccination rates for children are
continuing to decrease. This is not good. This
is causing diseases that were previously not so
rampant to get more prominent. And that is bad,
obviously. Take a look at
this being reported here.
Speaker 2: Hey there, everybody. U.S. childhood
vaccinations have dipped again this year. A new
report from the CDC suggests. What started
as a concern about the COVID 19 vaccine,
especially in younger people, is now carrying
over into other shots, too, including polio,
diphtheria and measles. It's likely one of the
reasons cluster outbreaks of diseases such as
measles are on the rise. CDC reports show last
year it was in the Twin Cities Minnesota area.
Currently, it's in and around Columbus, Ohio.
Speaker 3: But in the Columbus outbreak there,
over 85 cases and can be counting. That was
compared to last week's data. But over 30
of those kids were hospitalized and most of
those cases were in unvaccinated children.
Speaker 2: Dr. Denise Work is a pediatrician
who told me this new report shows overall those
receiving vaccines required by most states is now
at about 93%. It was at 95% just two years ago
before the pandemic began. Hey there, everybody.
Speaker 1: So I know that decrease may not seem
hugely significant, but it is. And to see
it starting to be a trend now that we have
a number of years out from this initial decline
that we saw is concerning here from Yahoo! News.
Vaccination rates for kindergarten students
are falling. Childhood vaccination rates have
fallen for the third year in a row, according
to a new report from the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention. The report found that 93%
of kindergartners receive state required vaccines
during the 20 2122 school year, a drop of two
percentage points from the 2019 2020 school year.
So. This is obviously concerning just for health
reasons. And we are seeing the effect pretty
immediately of this decrease in vaccinations
where we're seeing outbreaks that are unexpected,
at least within the context of the last
number of years and decades and these
types of diseases. If everyone or almost
everyone was getting vaccinated for them,
we want to have the issues that we're having
now with, in this case children. And so then
the question is why? And there's more than
just the one that's coming to our all of our
brains right now, but obviously the one that
we have the most control over. Is the anti-vax
sentiment that spread during COVID. And so it's
not say, all of that percentage is to blame.
Not all of that is the fault of anti-vaxxers,
but you have to attribute a good amount to it.
And that is what we're getting out of the public
health community that now that so many individuals
are bought into their political beliefs about the
vaccine and how it's maybe a Bill Gates microchip
or whatever, they believe they don't feel safe
getting the vaccine so they don't get their kids
vaccinated and it has negative consequences.
And so this is another example of when.
Misinformation and disinformation have real world
consequences. It matters. It matters to have the
proper sources giving you your information about
subjects as important as the health of your
children. And unfortunately, too many people in
the United States do not have that. What so ever